is louder with crowder is brought to you
in part by.com
[Music]
youtube heroes
[Laughter]
[Music]
last i left you black oh mugskibar was
pumping mugs under the youtube radar in
record time and the elites in silicon
valley were starting to notice
but like any success tale triumph always
comes with its own whole new set of
hiccups
okay
question
superior
stranger
two
[Music]
off their dad no
you're lois
that boombox
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
a little hot everything's going to taste
like a rubber for a little while i have
a i have a i bit my tongue the day right
in the tip of my tongue and now it's
turned into a canker thor oh so i'm
talking like brian stelter you poor
thing
so uh that accent's coming up isn't it
we have a lot to yes we have a lot to
get to today um we're going to of course
uh black history month we've always
honored that here at ladder with crowder
we have our black history facts we honor
it uh really i would say more
reverentially reverently
than
most programs and ironically it
coincides
right now with the left being uh more
blatantly racist out in the open than i
think
they intend to be
so we'll be talking about whoopi
goldberg we'll be talking about john
oliver we'll be talking about some of
the incidents that have been occurring
uh and uh
you know wrapping this all up in a nice
bow it's always sort of ironic to me
when uh people on the left say well
don't see anyone through a group
let's not group people together
what
well unless you're dividing them right
yes exactly or promoting one group over
the other right exactly it depends on
which it's like well yesterday you were
black and we you know we needed you to
burn down a few buildings today we need
uh we need a mail to set the penn state
uh swimming records
so you've served your purpose
uh by the way if we're and who knows
because we're gonna be hitting some
third rails today oh boy uh we hit third
rails every day if you miss us here on
youtube this is the only it's just if we
don't tell you that we're not going to
be doing a show the next day that means
the show is still going on you can tune
in on rumble or of course on mug club uh
where we do an extra full hour of show
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern i
know sometimes we start with 10 i mean
like 10 15. but that's an old comedy
club rule we start a little late because
you guys keep funneling in if you're mad
at us
don't tune in at 10 15.
blame comedy it's your fault uh and
today we'll be playing playing newest
gender pronouns i really do have the
lisp in the tongue yeah it's a little
it's a list of the song you should just
lean into it it's like i was stung by
bees like macaulay culkin and my girl
are you going to die on [ __ ] get my
glasses uh you don't wear glasses and uh
i also have a question for you what do
you know about the model minority theory
we're going to be talking about that
comment below before you watch it it's
always interesting for us to see what
you know and people will often comment
the best thing is to comment and then
comment below your comment once you
watch the segment and see if your
opinion has changed we're going to get
into john oliver and of course the
lawsuit right now with harvard
uh one of the carolina universities i
always forget which one
uh the good one
i don't know is that a good one in my
mind i'm gone too
one of the carolinas so before we move
on we have gerald a here uh the blow-up
doll is in repair how are you i'm doing
well that blow-up doll is dead steve and
i killed it you can't kill an animator
yes you can but it's spirit lives on how
are you i'm okay i haven't slept really
it happens every now and then why i
don't know no i have no idea why i think
it was uh you don't have a checkup today
uh-huh so you know i get a little
nervous when you have your little
checkups you get nervous for a checkup
well i just want to make sure that i
beat the test and uh we also have here
in the studio you know you'll love them
uh and he's going to be with me just so
we have announcements coming up go to
lotto with crowder.com tour i am going
to be back on the road with this
gentleman doing stand-up now first time
since the pandemic started uh you can
bring it do you have the overlay there
uh the next show we do together is march
26th victoria theater in evansville
indiana you can go buy the tickets and
uh we have a few more dates that will be
coming up probably about five dates this
spring dave landau how are you sir ahoy
good and this weekend the denver improv
yeah i i have a hemorrhoid it's
ridiculous i've never had one well oh
and uh dave this we're we're live i
thought you were sitting a little taller
it's the inner tube no it's i'm not
gonna use a donut i'm gonna take the
pain okay i don't think so
i just didn't want to look at that in a
mirror i've never done it i have no idea
what token owen's looking at he's
looking down at it were you looking at
your sub have you had a hemorrhoid he's
looking down like this the entire time
maybe he's got a hemorrhoid too he could
have a hemorrhoid i don't really i don't
really think that a physical examination
through his pants would help
what do you think you know we're going
to be talking about asians today there
token walnut yeah you excited about it
real excited yeah yeah you sound it yeah
hey by the way did you did you know this
did you know kamala harris did you know
she's uh she's eight she's the first
asian vice president right that's what
you're telling me do you do you claim
her as one of your own absolutely not
okay
she's a lot of first house not a first
thing vice president she's been rejected
by many racialists there's a lot of
people that don't claim her that was a
fact she's the first president vice
president yeah she's a last-round draft
pick and then traded
i think that's the first sort of a woman
speaking of which the first thing we are
going to get to your favorite stephen
colbert i love colbert
yesterday he made this now you know
about the spotify controversy we
addressed it yesterday uh with joe rogan
it's absurd talk about orwellian uh
everyone else trying to exert their
pressure blackrock group they're trying
to of course make sure that you have all
these warnings well you know you would
think that stephen colbert being an
entertainer someone who uh
necessarily
should defend freedom of speech of
course
of course is a little different when you
work for one of the major media
conglomerates created this cringy fake
ad
i'm sorry they refer to it as sketch but
fake advertisement uh condemning spotify
for misinformation here we go
we here at spotify have been under fire
recently for amplifying covet 19
misinformation
in fact our podcasts have faced so much
scrutiny that most people haven't even
noticed that we're also spreading
misinformation with music
introducing spotify misinformation
playlists all your favorite songs
strategically assembled in an order that
results it's going to be multiple
inaccuracies you'll get
i heard the shot changes the shape of
you one day you're only human the next
day she wolf 50 homo sapien 50
lady coyote
everybody will say oh my god who let the
dogs out
our playlists are sure to have you
moving your body away from medicine did
you know the covet vaccine may cause
discoloration of the urine or feces and
also big balls testing inflation swollen
nuggets and gigantic jewels after i got
back my humps hurt so log on to spotify
where we hit shuffle on your
understanding of basic facts this
stephen colbert company sketch has been
brought to you by pfizer oh well that
explains it ah
oh i do love mad libs yes
i think i felt the tumor grow while i
was watching that that's just your
hemorrhoid oh is it yeah is it not just
hope i think it's benign
it's more of a friction burn really i
sure hope it's malignant uh here's the
thing
think about this for a second we live in
an era we genu where anti-fascists are
supporting mandates punching people in
the face who demand freedom
and we live in an era where entertainers
and comedians are trying to get other
comedians removed for opinions well
actually for interviewing people yes
doctors did well
some would say when you have a phd and
you may be helped you know well it's not
like the those with phds in philosophy
who condemn drugs
the point remains yes just because you
have a phd in virology from harvard does
not make you an expert no no i've always
said that no it's the third string
writer at colbert who should be telling
us what to inject into our body yes i
really enjoyed that
what was the budget on that i hope that
was nothing yeah can you imagine the
pitch meeting it's like just imagine
this we open
on microphones yeah yeah because we're
talking about podcasts and then we turn
up the volume and it's like they go do
you mind if we have someone sit in here
and it's one of those drug
representatives like what that happened
one time another doctor's office and
they said by the way do you mind if we
have someone sit in there who they say
well she's here for uh uh pryla sec i
was like what no no she's not no and by
the way she's attractive and you're
about to you know put a finger up my ass
no i don't want her to sit in the only
misinformation in that is that it was
comedy yes
i don't understand how in any way what
it
just
my head hurts
this is neil young was
anti-establishment that was the whole
thing well back then well no it turns
out he's just a selfish prick who only
cares about his own wallet because he
doesn't care about you he doesn't care
about anything you don't walk away what
the spotify royalties he didn't want
that who cares the guy's a
multi-millionaire somebody has a
different opinion difference of opinion
we have no idea
what the actual results of these
vaccines and boosters will be in the
future that's a fat word
no it's a factual statement actually
because there can be no long-term
studies that's true there are no
long-term studies so we don't know so
talking to different doctors about their
opinions is in no way misinformation
yeah the only thing that is
misinformation is this guy who used to
be i guess a comic telling people that
it's misinformation right yeah but he
needs the dollar bills from pfizer
mm-hmm
big fish could be madonna
it's unlikely but how about missed out
on the johnson and john how did did they
watch the dancing needle sketch and they
were like you know what guys what we
need to do is take this we need to make
it shittier yes there are a way we can
do that
we can't afford dancing needle costumes
this time we want to take what we did
that upset everybody with the dancing
needles and let's build some real
momentum with that okay good we just go
to google and take uh album covers right
and see if anything sort of looks like
medicine let's just put them together
like it's a board game because that's
pretty much well i heard that jimmy
fallon just kills by smashing eggs on
one of the hemsworth brothers heads so
this is going to be gold
he just referenced baja men i know the
bar is so low that you don't get lower
than that tomorrow's sketch is going to
be a deep dive into the macarena
and how it swept the country hey hey
kids have you heard of
mambo number five
it wasn't me
you're blue the vaccine is a lie what
about that would that be funny no oh no
because it'd be it's misinformation i
don't know like are we have we just
become old we're out of touch that this
is what the the the kids find funny no i
think it's the opposite i think it's old
people watching this and going that's
clever i didn't even know they made that
song it is because they've been trapped
inside for two years because every show
they watch it's just terrifying it's
either days of our lives or this yeah i
think his audience is basically the uh
basically the equivalent of the victim
in scarface where they hold his eyes
open to make them watch his friend die
only it's cold air you're gonna watch to
go there now
i think whatever boomer can you imagine
a boomer's life it's just watching tv
that tells you to buy catheters
like fall you'll fall down a staircase
you should wear a life alert necklace
you're gonna die in the tub you're gonna
catch a vaccine every day's just or
you're gonna not a vaccine you're gonna
need a vaccine you catch a fight like
every day is just terror that you're
gonna die yeah well they are and you're
all yeah but you're already so close you
live you live with the hope that that
hover round will get you to the grand
canyon
will that one charge get me from here
why not live your life the most at that
age well you know because it doesn't
sell you want them in front of the tube
you want every boomer in front of the
tube watching your vaccine sketches i
don't know if it's a violation of payola
laws you know where you need to let
people know if there's an advertisement
because they think bill devayne's silver
dollar says bitcoin
reverse mortgage dave it's all in
revenue yeah what we do is we give tom
selleck our house
and he pays us and then we leave you
kids with debt
and then i took the vaccine because that
nice man in the needle costume told me
to but i have lupus and now i wear a
leather helmet and my head touches my
shoulder blade your father got the
myocarditis i found him in the basement
eight days later but it's better than uh
drinking fish tank cleaner like our old
president said at least that's what
colbert told me he said to inject bleach
yes
gosh ah okay hey you know what little
bit of a silver lining here let's get a
glimmer of light because it is black
history month
so yeah uh we honor uh black historical
moments
in history here black history month they
get a whole month it's a little you know
well they get a whole month every
well leap year and it's that it's the
shortest months yeah that's what i'm
saying well every now and then they get
a longer month
every i mean come on we could do better
i don't well the gays get a longer month
they well and then the blacks get a lot
of extra days here's the thing who do
you think who do you think signed off on
black history month okay of course it
was a white guy and why do you think
they picked february fine fine give them
like ah if only there were like a month
that isn't really a movie
february black history month done
what one is gay history month march july
i
it has to be in a warmer month obviously
because you can't wear the outfits yeah
if you want to if you want to parade
naked down the street you need some eat
yeah
january
oh our month is supposed to be february
can we give it to the blacks i i can't
wear my leather chains in this we don't
like the cold man guess where to stand
still
[Laughter]
so today we honor specifically celebrate
safely inside yes
me
i love rockets
i hope you're ringing i hope you have
your inner tube see so
we celebrate moments in black hollywood
history so uh a couple of black history
facts and uh you know all references are
available louder with crowder.com we
always provide a references link in the
description 1939 hattie mcdaniel became
the first black woman to win an academy
award for supporting role in gone with
the wind oh wow look at that do you have
one too you know that hollywood yes i do
in 1963 sydney poitier was the first
black man to take home the oscar for his
leading role in lily's of the field they
call me mr lilies
and uh at a 1960 screening of psycho
calvin watson of peoria illinois was the
first uh black man to yell [ __ ] you got
a knife in a crowded movie theater yeah
that's right true yes yeah effective
also in honor this is a unique uh time
in history because in honor of uh black
history month merging with the chinese
new year they're converging chinese new
year yeah it was yesterday um
and also this is the year of the tiger
did you know that it is so we just so
put it all together to show um uh uh the
historical interactions between the
different cultures uh over this past
year the suspect in that vicious attack
on a 65 year old asian american woman in
hell's kitchen
is a convicted murderer out on parole
after killing his own mother
38 year old brandon elliot's under
arrest tonight he's facing assault and
hate crime charges he was released from
prison just two years ago after serving
a little over a decade for killing his
mother
that brutal head stomp attack on a 61
year old asian man in harlem the suspect
arrested is now charged with a hate
crime that victim remains in a coma i
need to review the clips before honor
you didn't tell me that was a white
supremacy montage to survivor oh
no it's terrible man well the song was
actually on the newscast that was the
weird thing yeah it was i don't know
what they're doing now and i don't know
how they get the copy right someone's
greasing the palms a little bit
but we're gonna have more black history
month facts for you tomorrow because
it's black history month
[Music]
i think just under a decade is fair for
killing your mother that's exactly what
i was thinking like what hey speaking of
black and uh historical artifacts whoopi
goldberg
is uh still live
yeah she was uh discussing yesterday
sister act yes oh both one and two back
in the habit yes
or as i refer to it
the better actor the better actor the
better actor yeah i mean it's rare
sequels are funnier yeah i know
especially funnier than one i mean it
goes home alone two and then sister act
two yep because at this point like oh
how is she gonna disguise herself now i
know it
she blends in
also why is it like it's just like it's
a choir and she's the only black woman
if i'm remembering correctly like how
many choirs have you seen uh you know
that's a fair point yeah and if you're
gonna hide her will you hide her in a
choir with more yes diversity exactly
i've never seen a choir of nuns and i
was raised catholic well that's true too
i've never seen them either that's
because they were shoot out by the
priest do you think i gotta gross i
gotta be honest i've never seen a black
nun i i'm just that's oh like well yeah
none but my point is she didn't have to
be a nun she could have you know been at
farrakhan's shirt but as far as black
nuns there are none yeah
oh lord dad jokes thank you this is
where we are my dad joke my dad they've
been initiated now with the twins yeah
just turning everything into a song
maybe keep it to yourself i will know so
uh well i just haven't seen one i'm
sorry
no we haven't seen black nuns i grew up
in detroit in a catholic listen
it's it's a cultural thing many black
women they don't like to fly
that's true
so
yesterday uh when discussing the
tennessee school that uh that banned the
book malls
and i say
uh whoopi goldberg which is an excellent
book by the way whoopi goldberg
said
and this is what we're this is the theme
today
uh i i i think i've put my finger on it
and we always want why hold on a second
why do they say this is racist on the
left and what
oh
they have no idea what racism actually
is as seen by whoopi goldberg yesterday
saying
that the holocaust
let me just be clear the holocaust
was not in fact about race no i know you
think this is this is real close
tennessee school pulled the graphic
novel mouse out of their lessons on the
holocaust because it contained some
nudity and some bad language personally
i'm colorblind because you know
given
the story of mouse i'm i'm surprised
that that's what
that's what made you uncomfortable the
fact that there was some nudity and uh
i mean it's idiotic it's about the
holocaust the killing of six million
people but that didn't that didn't
bother you but the the making i'm not
sure that they don't use the naked part
as a kind of a canard yeah to throw you
this is why people do it into wiping
yeah so this is you know you all go
fight amongst yourselves but you know
the whole sunny hospital
race
no no
it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about race
because you it's about man's inhumanity
to man
so
first of all though let me just jump in
here
they're mice it's not about nate naked
people at all no just no i she didn't
read it well i don't know if you heard
that she didn't know it was going i mean
this is what happens when you just put
uh
when you just put five hot flashes at a
table
in morning
morning tv
so let me get this clear and i'll get to
it i don't disagree with her i wouldn't
have disagreed with her point entirely
i'm giving her some grace here if she
would have explained it properly which
she didn't right but more importantly so
we'll be goldberg on a second the
holocaust
you know all about the aryan uh you know
supremacy right
that's where we get white supremacy
effectively from when we're discussing
it today so that's not about race but
whoopi all of these other things with a
montage coming up
were
i hate to ask this question but
you have aligned yourself with the man
who
has bashed women
made
countless racist remarks and show them
you're ben carson why would you why
would you assign align yourself with
that like i'm going to explain to bill
barr now who says there is no system
systemic racism eric gardner george
floyd couldn't
breathe brianna taylor police did not
philando castile he told them i have a
gun tamir rice was 12. now if you can't
look at that and say hey we have an
issue and we got to sit down and talk
about it and the problem i have is the
only way to become a good republican is
to become a democrat according to the
media and i just i don't know what to do
anymore because i can't keep coming on
uh tv every day saying that we're all
nazis and and you know hitler's salutes
and whatever it's just not
intellectually honest
well i have to say let me just say
something
for for poops and giggles
the republicans have brought this on
themselves they've brought this view of
them
on themselves
you shouldn't talk about you know racism
well you should because we've seen it
you should for four years uh directed at
various people so here's the let me make
sure that i understand this uh donald
trump republicans ben carson um
these are all i just want to make sure
that i understand someone who votes
republican someone who votes for donald
trump someone who is in the cabinet of
donald trump who happens to be a black
man these are all examples of racism
these are examples of problems that are
all predicated on race but the actual
movement
that took place in germany which
resulted in the in their mind necessary
eradication of an entire race of people
predicated on the idea of one and only
one superior aryan race is not oh i i
see i understand now you don't know what
racism is
that that would be the point right and
she doubled down on i love it she never
even bothered to look at okay well maybe
i don't think it's about race but um
jewish people you know typically middle
eastern descent can be part of that mix
okay so that's not necessarily white but
also how did hitler view it
because he only had been quoting that
the jews were a race that needed to be
wiped out since 1919. it wasn't like
the 30s was like an epiphany moment
she's trying to whoopi wash hitler he's
like i have to do this because of the
race of the jews i don't think you mean
because of their race yes i do don't
speak for me does not speak for me no i
think it's just about human nature no
it's racism i hate the ice stop speaking
i like how gerald the guy who looks like
he just jumped out of hitler's birthday
cake pointed out the jews aren't white
that was what he just brought to this
couple of years past hitler just to be
clear old blonde hair blue eyes want you
to like uh
can you i mean this is one and i get it
like jesus one but the rest of them well
actually jesus was black if you wouldn't
know but race doesn't matter doesn't it
but it was black happy no you're right
israelites only only black jews it was
white on white crime uh i i don't think
there was any bigotry involved with the
holocaust no no no no no it was just one
you know you know what she fails to
point out is
yeah the other six million people that
were killed by hitler were black gypsies
professors gays ripples like it was a
little bit of ableism going on a little
bit right lim different people were
different
the internet to help beat the nazis was
then chemically castrated for being gay
well you know by neil young yeah it was
no no no no no this is gonna
hurt i
don't want a gay grocer this is the
issue that is really taking place though
is
there's a disc there's a growing
disconnect sort of like we talked about
with true dosing this fringe minority
and these views are not acceptable we
talked about that yesterday this is the
silver lining whoopi goldberg thought
that she and they tried to save her
yes it wasn't it wasn't about race
they're like uh
i mean if they could back away from that
set you know but they can't
can't put wheels on those chairs they're
not they're not weight tested to the
the the issue here is is they don't know
what race they're so far beyond the
actual definition of races when they've
continued to change the definition of
racism that they go well hold on a
second what could we all agree upon when
people say find common ground
if we can't all agree on the idea that
the nazis particularly hitler the idea
of a supreme aryan race and eradication
of non-aryans is racist then we're not
going to find common ground no you never
will and by the way the american
defamation league anti-defamation league
i did that yesterday yeah well that's a
problem i definitely don't we don't pay
attention to those pro-definitions yeah
exactly they changed the definition of
racism on their website and actually now
i'm jack it's white supremacy
it's it's just white supremacy against
people of color yeah it used to be
classifying a group of people or using a
kind of prejudice to say something about
a group of people whether they were
white black hispanic asian didn't matter
you were just saying that this group of
people is inferior because of this
because of their race well because they
have not anymore just like the cdc had
to change the definition of immunization
well you know like well it was that
before that's what racism was that we
agreed upon uh but that's not what it is
anymore well you're talking about the
holocaust happened at a time where it
was like irish germans you know italians
jews they wouldn't date right stuff like
that you know
everybody kind of didn't like each other
even at this time jews was very it was
very specifically racist and also even
on that note shame on the school like
that's a book
that i've read that i think is extremely
important and it's it's it's written by
uh it's a holocaust survivor yeah and
it's it's
you know it's it's not as funny as
schindler's list but it's uh not as feel
good no it's still no but it's it's it's
this really great book if anybody ever
if you ever want to even teach your kid
about the holocaust because it's done
with mice and it's it's it's a graphic
novel and it's an excellent book about
the holocaust it's like it's
heartbreaking of course and the fact
that you would pull it out i just don't
buy the fact that you're pulling it out
because mice are naked in it when are my
clothes well do you know why they want
to pull it out the same reason they want
to pull out to kill a mockingbird we'll
talk about that tomorrow and it's not
republicans is because if they keep
telling children that everything is
racist for example she used to me rice
as an example well you can say that
that's just race or you can see that it
was a kid in a hoodie who looked like he
was 25 aiming a replica gun at people in
a park and the cops were concerned right
you can say that there are examples of
police brutality but it's not entirely
predicated on race sometimes you can
find that the idea the the aryan race
was
the premise was there is one race one
race to rule them all and it's the tall
blonde hair blue eyes guy until schmelin
got his ass kicked by joe lewis they're
like oh boys there's black people out
there hey explosive
then they hosted the olympics and uh
they lost in the races it's because they
want two races white and black no it's
because that doesn't fit their narrative
that is well but i think if you have
children reading this book about the
holocaust if you have children reading
to kill a mockingbird or they also see
real racism and they see someone
combating real racism they'll go oh
that's what racism is yeah not the fact
that you you know we don't hit a quota
at uh quota at uh brown right not the
fact that we don't have black people at
yale not this idea that um the nuclear
family as black lives matter says is
racist oh no that's silly there are
actual historical examples of racism but
if you point to those guess what it
makes it really hard to sell kids on the
idea that america is systemically racist
so let's get rid of those historical
examples so we can rebuild racism in
whoopi's modern image well did you see
how she tried to kind of pivot and say
and they're not they don't have any
problem with the holocaust the killing
of of jews and i was like wait what they
they pulled it out okay let's assuming
your argument is correct dave that it
was my
naked i haven't read this book yeah but
not just naked yes let's see yeah advice
that's one of the creepiest crazy oh my
goodness well they said there was foul
language too is there any do we know of
any foul language that they've been able
to show because if you're showing that
to a kid at a certain age and there's
bad language in it you probably either
want to scrub that a little bit for them
if it's like a you know a seven-year-old
or an eight-year-old and nine i don't
know yeah you don't want to have like
any swears when you're watching people
that's true
well no you want to focus on what's
important in this right yes the tragedy
of what happened you don't have to use
bad language you don't have to use
nudity if there were other stuff the
mice thing is stupid but she tries to
paint everybody who has a concern about
a book is saying oh you don't want to
teach about the holocaust no i want
people to understand where it came from
why it happened so we can avoid ever
having it again and you guys are the
fascists now and i don't entirely here's
the thing i understand i would
understand the point she was trying to
make if she said for example well look
actually world war ii when you look at
nazi germany how did hitler come to
power because we're never actually
allowed to ask this question doesn't
mean that you support hitler the nazis
you say okay they were internationally
embarrassed right with the treaty of
versailles economically they were
crippled okay and so then race was used
right it was used as a weapon so that
they could create a scapegoat with the
jews that's how you got to that point if
she was trying to say so it's not just
about race but it's actually about a a
litany of factors that then race became
sort of the pinnacle uh and of course
the boiling point no instead she just
it's about human nature it's some people
are bad it's the holocaust was bad on
the way in a guy cut in front of me
didn't use his turn signal it's
ridiculous crazy no it's about othering
people and we've known this throughout
history that any time that you say
another group of people is the cause of
all of our problems right it's a
dangerous thing to do do you see the
company can i do it with any of the
views yeah but what's going on right now
you're telling them that a group of
people should be separated a group of
people are unclean a group of people are
responsible for all the problems going
on in the country and you have a book
that shows how extremely dangerous it
can be and a book that's very touching
and real yeah and you miss them and kids
read that and go wait a second it starts
by othering people it starts by creating
two classes of citizen something
something unvaccinated i don't know let
me go back to the mice i mean here's
this is important this is why they don't
want statues this is why they don't want
certain history taught because history
makes it clear when you understand it
contextually do we have slavery in the
united states we absolutely did we fight
one of the bloodiest wars in history to
end slavery we still do it's called
trafficking yep it's called trafficking
good point and uh but now to her credit
we'll be they don't talk about that a
whole lot uh whoopi uh did issue an
apology this morning we want to make it
clear she said uh on today's show i said
the holocaust is not about race but
about man's inhumanity to man i stand
corrected she sits corrected
i stand on my walker with the tennis
balls corrected the jewish people around
the world have always had my support and
that will never waver well uh i was
sitting in my shower chair correctly
my feet hurt
life alert
hover around it's great child give me an
example of you supporting the jewish
people around the world whoopi
i would like to know what that means
yeah do you support moving the uh did
you support moving the embassy back to
jerusalem that's crazy what do you like
you don't give me a frozen hot pocket
and i put it under my titty it gonna be
warm
whoopie oven
what will i do for a klondike anything i
will literally do anything even
whitewash the holocaust okay
you don't know me you know how far i
will go for a klondike you don't know
where i've been
all right
i don't know you guys let me know do you
think that's what it is i i want to put
a fine point on it if this is reductive
i think the left just doesn't know what
racism is and they don't want your
children to know what racism is i think
it's deeper i think it's deeper but i
think you're right i'm not saying you're
wrong either but i do i think it's
deeper i think it's at this point it's
become it's not even conspiratorial it's
just obvious well they know what it is
what they don't want people to realize
well we had it better
yeah we're ripping down we're ripping
down statues of history we've been doing
this for so long we've been dividing the
country for so long we've been telling
people that they're unclean we've been i
mean and now we're trying to shake it so
people in my opinion are two races you
either want to consider yourself you're
going to be either be majority or
minority that's right yeah well dave we
were telling you you were unclean
because you hadn't showered in a while
first of all i showered twice it's not a
hemorrhoid it turns out the eastern
section
i've never had a hemorrhoid though what
do you do about it uh well i think you
stop straining so much all right we do
have to move it we have so much to get
do we have a rebuttal here i don't know
if we're gonna have time to do all this
today boris johnson uh apollo do we want
to do the john oliver look if if
if 4 000 people click like before i get
through what do we have right now the
next two stories
uh we'll do the john oliver rebuttal i
think if we don't do it so smash that
like button smash that like button
because we have a pretty thorough
rebuttal to john oliver and it's always
fun but i don't know if we have time do
you have the you have the like button
there too yeah
all right there we go four thousand
within the next five minutes i can't say
that anymore all right so nine thousand
now okay boris johnson all right so if
it gets to thirteen thousand then we'll
continue it'll just be a little bit of a
long show today uh boris johnson had to
apologize for um what's now being
referred to as partygate for people who
don't know the british prime minister
um there was a report published by susan
gray about how boris johnson partied
while the country was locked down yeah
so it's not exclusive to gavin newsom
now this happened people were outraged
and you probably saw you know there was
video circulating of him apologizing to
his credit the thing is what you saw was
the whitewashed version of his apology
oh really yeah it was again context
matters more than content and uh we here
have actually procured we don't have the
video for the because they shut off the
cameras we have the full unedited
apology uh of boris johnson uh for
partygate
and i would like to take this moment to
sincerely apologize for the parties that
were hosted during lockdowns they were
unbecoming and unprofessional and truly
sorry uh for all of it the gathering the
like masks the champagne the whole lot
what about the feather dusters oh yes of
course the mishap with the feather
duster the french maid outfits like i
said all of it and the garden hose with
the sprinkler head and the garden hose
with the sprinkler head like i said all
of it i apologize for the parties the
champagne the feather dusters the maid
outfits and yes the garden hose with the
sprinklers don't forget the ball gags
yes and the small replicas we've been
placed in jelly balloon they're not even
symmetrical and the mom yes now we need
him to rehash the specific spot i do
apologize for the parties the champagne
the french-made outfits the feather
dusters the garden hose yes the big ben
replicas and the jelly balloons the bull
gags and the marmots oh they didn't even
ask for the big ben balloon and he used
it on me he was asking for it with your
eyes what about the eyes wide shut mess
all right to be a pig you got the pig
mask i was the rabbit and the mom
yes yes as i said i've apologized for
the lot of it under the umbrella of the
party that did in fact include
the champagne the gatherings the parties
the lights the feather duster the french
made mishap the garden hose with the
sprinkler head the big ben replicas in
the jelly balloon the eyes wide shut
masks uh and yes the
marmots
it's like a badger at the moment
it hurts
if it's in the wrong place
well
across the pond they do things
differently they do their own cultures
i see boris johnson the team oh hell
that's it
[Laughter]
we need to do a pc 48 hours reboot
you've cut out all the movies all right
well you guys eight minutes long you
guys smashed the like button uh more
than enough of you so okay we're gonna
do this story jerks the supreme court
just so you know right now we'll we'll
set it up with this the supreme court
actually uh just last week i believe
announced that it is going to hear the
cases uh against the race-based
admissions at harvard and the university
of uh north carolina and this is
something where a lot of people are
upset about how um asian americans are
being treated at universities
so harvard uses uh subjective measures
like quote i'm quoting these here
references available at rescuer.com
likability kindness to keep out asian
students so they're using sort of
subjective measures to say well these
are actually more important than say
your scores on the standardized tests
because asian americans uh actually need
to score also 250 points higher what on
the sats
i didn't even send blacks and latinos on
average to be admitted into these
schools yeah so
um
why is this overtly racist and i do mean
racist
practice allowed to con
still
why does it still exist today that's
still
with a lisp
that's what's happening right here
before i move on what is with the weird
faces on cnn i just don't it's like it's
the weird face patrol i think it's the
spacing of the eyes i think they want
you to be slightly off like her one eye
i think she's just a little drunk yeah
like in her her one-eyed drifts like
she's pinterest mom drunk yes yeah just
like a little bit of yeah i ate fruit
for dinner it's one of those jumbo wine
glasses
that's mine
be careful those are the people that buy
right
um
by the way speaking of which you can
follow us uh on tick tock uh for people
who still care about that uh chai com
service but uh they've banned us three
times i guess we're still oh billions of
people uh and we'll be taking your chat
here yeah i guess
i'm just gonna let you know you know i
do the social like i do a lot of my i
don't do all of it but twitter instagram
stuff tic tac i have nothing to do with
so whatever that it wasn't me kids
remember mumbo number five
huh
for more of that go to my buddy kimmel
dogs out woof huh well that was a good
song never mind
let me teach you how to dougie remember
your friend putting that cd in and you
punching him in the face watch tomorrow
stephen colbert's going to plank
okay wait
[Laughter]
next week he's eating tide pods so um
here's something i want to set this up
here because fingers crossed the the
left two they want to white wash racing
like we just saw with the holocaust uh
uh what's that name that hajj uh what's
the name the guy does that uh that
patriot act on netflix uh jeffrey ross
no
no minaj something oh menage a trois yes
ah
i know you talked about one it was uh
assange
is that his name yeah he's a comic he
tours yeah
yes yes comic uh he does that show there
where he talked about the uh you know
the model minority myth i know he did a
show on that i think we did that a long
time ago but here's the thing they want
to erase racism where it actually
existed
and
wants to continually oppress people
today
depending on which group it is they want
you to think i should say here's
actually it's a beautiful it's a
beautiful trick if you think that you're
oppressed in a way that is not true
it allows the person perpetuating that
lie to actually oppress you
just like hitler lied right hitler lied
it predicated it on race he made lies
about people's specific ethnicity
specific race and that of course allowed
him to oppress people not just the jews
a lot of them to oppress everybody allow
them to take control over everybody and
we're seeing that take place right now
with asian americans and the democrat
party uh so you see this with the
admissions into university the supreme
court case i'm interested to hear how it
goes let me just set this up to be clear
and at the end of this i'm going to
offer some solutions unlike john oliver
um and we did this segment a while ago
but it you know then it just came back
because the supreme court case yeah i
think everybody here agrees you should
get into university based on your grades
your qualifications period
we don't need to change our point of
view regardless of who's applying right
black white green
i don't think you want to have i was
about to say yellow but then you know
jesus loves me song is racist it really
is i think if you want to have crippling
debt for a pointless education that will
get you nowhere you have added yes
welcome it's the new american dream
good for you and if you want to work
hard and avoid going to university to
get a gender studies degree and maybe
perhaps apply yourself at a trade school
you can be assured that uh you'll be
paying for their useless
yeah
that's what student loan forgiveness is
well no it's you you made the money you
you spent the money you who made the
money you need to give you need to give
them the money to spend you can't just
make money and then not make them spend
money and then what do you think you're
just going to continue making this
retake no
when you're given the money you make
enough money come on it's forgiveness
it's loan forgiveness but when you're 18
you make stupid choices right yeah so we
should make all the 45 year olds pay for
the 18 year olds no no no when i was 18
i knew i wanted to do this and i'm still
doing it even though i drank and drove
into a tree yeah you don't make stupid
choices you have a dealer telling you
that college is going to solve all your
problems and oh you'll pay it off
eventually and we'll probably forgive it
so give it a whirl okay you played
foosball
so um
this is the model minority myth john
oliver tries to take this on and then
tries to well there there are so many uh
fallacies here they're going to have to
address them one by one so he tried to
argue against his perception of asians
as the model minority
and of course they predicate this on the
idea that look when you see white
americans saying hey they're not racist
for example look at how successful
asians are and they have no problem with
what what that really is is racism what
it really is is they're using a model
minority to be racist towards so
actually they're racist towards you so
if you keep telling people that white
folks are racist towards them maybe
they'll believe you especially if you
get rid of actual examples of racism
like i don't know the holocaust so uh he
actually tried to dispel this idea of
the model minority
myth as he calls it by using noted asian
uh
uh uh uh well just kamala harris asian
americans can sometimes be oddly
overlooked a recent survey asked
respondents to simply name a well-known
asian american and the results were not
good 42 percent of people said they
don't know one the next most popular
answers were jackie chan who's from hong
kong and bruce lee who died in 1973. oh
come on no disrespect to jackie chan and
bruce lee there but that is embarrassing
even before you consider the poll was
conducted while kamala harris who's
asian american was vice president how do
you [ __ ] up a question that easy now
first off this is the perfect example of
trying to instill white guilt before the
right white guilt to begin with
because most people i guess i guess i am
racist but you know what hold on a
second john oliver maybe people didn't
think of kamala harris as uh asian uh
american because of
kamala harris growing up my sister and i
had to deal with the neighbor who told
us her parents couldn't play with us
because she because we were black
good vibes like yoga
[Laughter]
[Music]
look at all those asian americans
okay do you have a favorite band
i'd say one of my favorites is bob
marley oh good choice uh you can't go
wrong with that that's a crowd pleaser
hard hitting questions your mixtape what
would be like your favorite three songs
oh okay let's see um
i aretha franklin um
anything of aretha franklin
i would say bob marley and then um
i don't know i love cardi b
[Applause]
yeah those aren't songs stupid
she's also the one that said she was
back in 1978 listening to tupac yeah
well yeah you know and smoking because
well maybe she is asian she you know
used her mouth she goes to make a time
machine of the song respect
shot the sheriff i don't just bob marley
just pick any oh uh and then she just
like in her head is like just name black
people just name black people aretha uh
coldplay shoot i'm running low uh uh
bruno mars is something right uh you
know you couldn't think of buffalo
soldier red hot chili peppers that's it
like she could never ever
she's such a big fan dave there's just
so much to choose actually yeah that's
oh oh by being i love oh bob marley
that's my favorite i saw that on a shirt
lobby something one one love
or two
ganja red stripe what you're racist so
look here's john oliver i just said he's
trying to set it up
who did he ask though honestly for this
interview whether you don't know an
asian american and you only know jackie
chan and bruce lee
he didn't knock on doors at a motel six
and it was [ __ ] a drunk guy who's
throwing beer cans at the television
right yeah do you have any asian friends
no
okay name and asian i don't know bruce
lee
what did you think about kamala harris
she's what huh
all right fine don't bother me generally
so i don't know yeah then she knocks on
the she knocks on the wrong door of the
wrong trucker i like a good agent washes
my room clean oh
it's you joyride i didn't know i should
have gone to the next room joyride all
right so this is the point that john
oliver tries to make like look at you
how did you not know that she was
asian-american namely because she
doesn't mention it unless it's
politically convenient i'm sure she'll
probably mention it with chinese new
year but then it'll be erased by her
talking about black history month
because she's going to place more
emphasis on that
this is an argument that john oliver
makes to try and make sure that you know
you're racist of course a lot of
americans who are not racist but who
recognize that there are disparities
between races in certain results so for
example academically asians tend to
excel athletically black americans tend
to excel right recognizing those
differences and maybe attributing some
of them for example with asians and
missions so culture
is in fact uh not that's actually racist
because that's not the case says john
oliver a central premise of the modern
minority myth is that the key to
overcoming american racism is simply
strong values and hard work with the
implication being that groups that
haven't succeeded simply haven't tried
hard enough as immigration law began
selecting for skilled and educated asian
immigrants the credentials of those new
arrivals seem to conform to the
stereotype which then took on a life of
its own especially in the civil rights
era as whites unnerved by black
americans radical challenges to the
system held up japanese and chinese
americans and their success as evidence
that they claimed disproved systemic
racism very basically america
prioritized wealthy more educated asian
immigrants then turned to black people
who'd been subjugated for centuries and
said see they're educated and successful
why aren't you okay first off you just
if you say it with a lilt
you somehow uh you act like it's an
insane question that's a perfectly
reasonable question actually
let's be clear about that also it
actually sort of flies in the face of
what he says later on in discussing
asian discrimination which occurred
actually pretty recently if you look at
world war ii anyway uh here's the thing
why was the united states
why was the united states able to find
these highly skilled immigrants from
asia in the first place okay uh it's if
we look at history it shows us that
culture is directly responsible for a
lot of this let me give you a couple of
examples and it has nothing to do with
melanin nick cannon uh a two-parent
family right we've talked about this two
parent households mom and dad
it's crucial
crucial it's actually if we're going to
talk about the single biggest
determining factor in uh your future
success
um
having a mom and having a dad and having
them active in your life it's not even
close people talk about repairing the
education system when people talk about
uh fixing our welfare social safety net
nothing if you did all those things if
you spent our entire gdp on those things
on these democrat policies since lyndon
johnson up until now on all of these
ideas that the left have pushed as some
kind of a solution to the racial
disparities in the united states it
would not have a discernible difference
on outcome
when compared
to having two parents in the household
we're talking about so look corner of
the united states let me get some stats
department of justice children from
single parent homes uh make up 71 of
high school dropout 75 percent of kids
and drug treatment programs 70 of state
incarcerated juveniles if you are
actually from a two-parent household you
have a mom and you have a dad active in
your life and this can include step
parents as well uh just to be clear
you are more likely to graduate school
you are less likely to be a criminal you
are more likely to be well-adjusted
mentally you are more likely to have a
long-term relationship that's healthy as
you get it's it's the single greatest
indicator that we have of future success
for children so culturally this matters
because
asian americans 85
of asian american children grow up in
two parent households
black americans 36 percent now let me be
clear about something i'll reference
available at lottoworthcredit.com when
you say oh hold on that's just rate no
no look look we are talking about
culture two-parent household because
guess what a black child with a
two-parent household is still better off
all of the future indicators for that
child a black child with two parents is
going to be better than a white or asian
child
in a single-parent household just to be
clear that's the beauty of it it's just
that there are so few black households
in america
where both mom and dad are active and
taking a role in the life it's very
common it's actually higher nation
households than any other uh minority
group in the united states right and so
the cultural part of this like this
didn't this wasn't always the case where
african americans had higher proportion
of single-parent families than everybody
else but they bought the lie
that's been sold to them and the black
community did not stand up and and i
understand like some people tried to but
they didn't stand up enough in force and
say look this is going to hurt us for
generations this like you said is the
single greatest indicator we have study
after study after study it's not white
men trying to control you it's not white
men trying to make sure that you do
things the right way it's saying this
will be beneficial to you and everything
that we see from blm and the left is
attacking the nuclear family bao limits
and their charges why no nuclear family
and by the way just so you know baby
mama is actually use that term right now
people say baby mama it's actually one
of the few sort of cultural i don't know
when you say idiom there would you say
just cultural colloquialisms that stems
from policy it stems from policy going
back to lyndon johnson it stems from the
model cities it stems from financially
incentivizing single-parent households
with welfare that's the thing baby mama
is actually the result of legislative
policy and it's a horrible thing to do
to a child not saying that some people
aren't widows some people aren't right
uh is it widowers as a guy uh you know i
don't know what a word yeah but widow is
it widower uh would oe i don't know the
plural i the point is let's not get too
lost in the weeds then we become john
oliver or whoopi goldberg and saying
that the holocaust says well when you
have a tiger mom like you when who yeah
breaks your pinky when you hit the wrong
piano yeah well yeah and jammed in your
neck you ever learned to play merry
little head a little lamb with your
thumb
not easy
so uh let me also go through
education go ahead no
please it's your show what really what
are we about to say nothing all right
education so we're talking about dual
parent households education these are
cultural examples do you believe that
for some reason asians because of the
color of their skin
stay together at a rate of 85 percent
versus 36 percent
you want to say that that's because of
race okay you're the racist let's go on
to education asian students spend four
times as much
time studying
as black americans they score an average
of eight points higher on the a.c.t
asian students have 13 percent higher
high school graduation rates than black
americans do you want to say that's just
because of their race
now here's let's
spoiler alert no okay the reason
the reason that you see these numbers
across the board again is because
culturally this is very important and
it's emphasized across uh asian culture
so this is also why it was possible for
america to import highly skilled people
from asia
as opposed to africans in the 50s and
60s and by the way i think that when we
are bringing immigrants into this
country i know the left will say this is
racist but not the holocaust yeah i
think that we should be bringing in
people who are skilled i think we should
be bringing in people regardless of
their race or where they're from who
actually improve the economic outlook
for the country i don't think you should
be bringing in the lowest the
non-skilled labor to take jobs away from
lower income americans it doesn't make
any sense and that's not been the policy
of any successful country as it relates
to immigration okay now let's look
across the world it's not just the
united states 30 percent
higher global school enrollment rates in
east asia versus sub-saharan africa okay
this is something that you see over
there and you see it modeled here as
well in the united states uh asian
americans value hard work and family
yeah seven to twenty percent more than
the general population not just black
americans of course that might have some
kind of an impact on their success later
in life you may say it's just because of
their race
right john oliver it's all race-based
ching cho i know what you're saying
well look when i just think you're
racist yeah yeah well when a culture
starts to value things right and it can
be a group of people it can be a country
whatever it is then people tend to go
towards that right so
asians they value like hard work and
sticking to a problem they've done
studies on this as well with white kids
we tend to strong units yep we tend to
give up on math problems that are
difficult after a shorter period of time
they'll sit there and they'll work on
those because culturally they have been
taught that there's benefit to doing
that right so in the african-american
community athletics do you think that
black people are just more athletically
gifted in in mass than everybody else
yes
i don't know i'm not saying that that's
true but it is pride it's true it is
prized it's a way out so many people
have said it is a way out of what i grew
up in and so they put time and effort
and energy into those things that they
value that's a good point but they're
also faster and they can jump
don't know that that's true
it's true i don't think it's true okay i
don't know if it's true just check every
human land speed record you're not going
to you're not going to find
a
jamaican guy yeah his name is bolt he's
got to be his name is both they kind of
were tip they kind of were you know
back in the deck on that one yeah but of
course they're they grow up to be like
doctors and surgeons they eat with
sticks yeah well i mean come on yeah
everybody's talking about people not to
mention cultivating rice much more
difficult than corn that's actually
there's a whole historical it's a whole
thing you got to wear a hat well malcolm
gladwell did some studies into this and
it was very interesting what he came to
and he's like look this is just a
cultural thing that has been passed down
from generations
don't say it's racism though to
acknowledge it and go oh hey guess what
if well this is what they try to hear
they try and cut it off at the past and
say now you must say that it's cultural
but that's racist no no it's not the
second you say that that means you're
trying to dispel the idea of it being
culturally related which is accurate so
that you can spew more of your special
brand of racism and i do mean racism
from john oliver just like we saw from
whoopi goldberg i don't think they have
hate in their heart for asian americans
just to be clear i don't think they're
nazis although whoopi i just don't know
why i just don't know why she feels the
nazis need a leg up but we'll go back to
that tomorrow it's just odd to me that
she would feel the need to defend
the fury like an apology i don't know
maybe she's mad at billy crystal about
something it could be
howard stern
um so when they do this i do think that
it's actually racist by what used to be
the definition of racism so um
this is something uh also that john
oliver does
and then he [ __ ] about dividing and
you know dividing people by racial
groups uh he says that we should not
consider asian americans successful
because there are certain subgroups of
asian americans who are struggling which
is not wrong but
okay just watch one of the main dangers
of treating asian americans as a single
entity is that it obscures the reality
of what is happening for the different
subgroups inside it for example about 10
percent of asian americans live in
poverty which is actually lower than the
overall u.s poverty rate but when you
disaggregate the data when you break it
down by subgroup you start to see a much
more complicated situation with
mongolian and burmese americans having a
poverty rate of 25
more than twice the national average and
when it comes to education while around
75 of indian americans have a bachelor's
degree well above the national average
for bhutanese americans that figure is
just 15
which is well below it the point is
disaggregating the data can reveal big
disparities that you couldn't see
previously oh you mean see people as
individuals though in this case you're
still seeing them as a group just a
subgroup of uh asians let me be really
clear before i get to the actual
percentages to rebut it uh this is where
they are misguided do you know why there
are certain groups and this is not just
with asians this is with immigrants of
all the more recently someone immigrated
the united states when you're looking at
the family the more likely they are to
live in poverty that's important to note
it means they haven't set their roots in
the country here
that allows prosperity to grow so let me
explain to you uh vast majority of asian
americans are what chinese 24 indian 21
filipino 19 vietnamese ten percent uh
korean nine percent japanese seven
percent let's compare it to john
oliver's examples mongolians less than
one percent and they're annoying they're
so annoying the chinese had to build a
wall the burmese one percent the
bhutanese less than one percent okay if
you look at the population for mongolian
burmese bhutanese americans most of that
boom has occurred since 2000 yeah okay
that they're not behind because they're
mongolian
we love their barbecue it's got the
thing and they do it and it's fun i put
on an egg
the key is the key is to put the meat in
first you're right the key is yeah meat
first it's not fun
i gotta i got a little walk in a line
and fill up my bowl and watch you cook
it on a thing well the food i want to
sit in order that's true the food is
good
it's a little bit of a self-checkout of
asian cuisine but
the food is tasty can we agree on that
yeah we can't agree on that you made a
really good point i'm saying you're
wrong i'm just saying it's a lot of work
for a restaurant no i know i yeah i get
it well if you look a little bit
automatically right he he so what he
said was true what you said like
track marks making your food like this
everyone
go ahead so the the time right the time
that you've been in this country it's
going to determine how much you have
progressed as a group of people like he
said but he's breaking down asian and
saying well these people are doing
better these people are doing better the
other factor is oh good
so you think that maybe culturally we
should look at and see well what is this
culture prize yeah do these do these
cultures tend to prize this the same way
that maybe this other indian culture
does or does do japanese cultures you
know prize this like mongolian cultures
we can actually look and see john you're
making a great point that maybe cultures
are a little different and i'm not
saying inferior or better i'm saying
that they prize things they hold things
to a higher esteem that maybe are more
valuable so and that's something to look
at to solve one thing you see across the
board for example if we look at the the
poverty rates of um united you know
natural-born uh chinese-american
citizens versus foreign foreign uh born
chinese they're 15 of them are in
poverty united states born nine percent
and you see this across a lot of
populations by the way you see this with
you know haitian americans who are born
in the united states uh who have had
families who've had roots you see the
same thing with latino americans the the
determining factor and isn't that a
beautiful thing but again let's not talk
about that because then that lets people
know that america's a better country
swedish you've heard me talk about this
many times when people point to the
nordic model
swedish americans it's true the average
swede has a higher uh what they call a
quality of living there's a sort of an
index that's created right a higher
quality or standard of life than the
average american but swedish americans
have a higher quality of life than
swedes in sweden same thing for danish
americans yeah well when everything's
given to you kind of for free i mean hey
do you like free stuff well yeah you tab
and then you sell us particle board and
make us put it together why would we
like you no no no no no not potato board
with steel ip no i'm in ikea so
it's this maybe blacks and whites and a
lot of us are born into america where we
have certain freedoms and certain
liberties and we
kind of coast a little bit where these
people come from other countries where
they've seen horrible surroundings yeah
and work their asses off to better
themselves so they might do a little bit
better because they try a little harder
they've seen is that possible i mean it
could be poverty i'm just saying i'm not
saying that's every case
but it's very possible also zack morris
did very well on his sats that's true oh
well not like that i didn't see this
later but he sits on that chair
backwards and my goodness does he look
cool now uh the earliest asian-american
immigrants like those from china this is
something also where john oliver just
again remember what he said before
rewind this if you need to because he
was talking about how white americans
point to them because they haven't
anyways the point is now he goes on to
say uh and i agree they've been
discriminated against actually
throughout this country
up until pretty recently too
asian immigration in that time was
essentially a cycle of economic
exploitation followed by a violent and
restrictive backlash this began with
chinese immigrants who were recruited to
work on the railroads in the 1860s they
faced virulent racism from the beginning
both from their bosses who saw their
lives as disposable and from whites many
of whom saw them as unfair competition
for jobs so here's the thing i
completely agree no one's saying that
america has a spotless path and i think
it's important to recognize that it's
not only black americans who face
discrimination here of course asian
americans have you have people who
aren't talking about the great great
great grandfather was a slave you have
people who they've seen their
grandfather who was put in an internment
camp that is significant also
significant no racial group has faced
systemic discrimination since the civil
rights act asian black or otherwise so
we now have enough of a data set now
let's go on to his next point because
the show is going a little bit long um
he talks about how living up to the
model minority stereotype inflicts
psychological damage on uh asian
americans here he goes whether or not
you're successful living a life defined
by a racist fantasy just isn't good for
you yeah striving to maintain the idea
of a racist fantasy is saying hey asians
are doing well severed my
self-esteem i agree but it's how that
really makes me feel better
nothing more than someone who could get
good grades someone who was supposed to
be perfect and be mom about everything
right by trying to be perfect your whole
life is going to be too much to bear
that kind of pressure can do real damage
suicide is the leading cause of death
for asian americans between the ages of
15 and 23.
i can't take the [ __ ] do you see the
light of hand that just took place there
again this is the problem with
presenting facts first off without any
context again references available at
loud earthquake.com we're this segment
has to be long because i think it
requires context i'm not trying to tell
you it's too complicated for me to
explain that's not what i'm saying i
want you to read up more on this so
check the references suicide um is the
leading cause of adolescent death he
says you know in the united states for
asian americans and he of course ties
that to this idea that the model
minority racism from the united states
basically all of us white guys and uh
asian men here no wonder you're still
alive you made it through your teen
years and you were listening to emo
combine asian with my chemical romance
those wrists are spotless and most of
them do with a sword if they get an
a-minus well well
they have a sword at the ready we had a
wooden spoon or a switch
oh
did you get a bee don't make me get a
sword draw oh i'm going to show the draw
which one will i choose you bring a much
shame to the family it's a worldwide
issue yeah it's not american asians who
commit suicide so the leading cause of
adolescent death
is suicide in korea in japan in china in
singapore so again what you see is a
hybridizing what you see is people bring
a portion of their culture here to the
united states and they bring by the way
both the good and the bad they bring in
industriousness they bring a value for
the nuclear family for family households
and they also bring societal pressure
that leads to
abnormally high suicide rates it's the
leading cause of adolescent death in
those countries and if you look at the
top countries as far as suicide rates
you always have japan korea they're
always somewhere near the top certainly
as far as it relates to the
industrialized world now
this pressure may come from the fact
that there's a big honor culture in asia
right a lot of pressure to do well your
family name means something i think you
get the point family where does this
pressure come from random people off the
street saying you're asian so you have
to be smart no it's coming from the
family so john oliver if the problem is
the family your whole argument goes away
yeah he wants you to believe that andrew
yang makes a math joke and then all of a
sudden people are plummeting from
rooftops so i actually even said a minus
i don't know if you saw this there was a
documentary um on the did you see this
last on the history channel oh yeah
about this it was on last night yeah
yeah yeah yeah we have a clip
[Music]
recently a series of archaeological digs
in phongwon china have unearthed ancient
evidence suggesting just how important
honor was in these confucian-based
societies
[Music]
asians
now yeah i never realized what a
cultural appropriator uh david carradine
was yeah no hey i didn't know he was
still alive no that was his uh no he's
not so well that was that him hanging
himself uh the auto erotic that was the
asian equivalent of taco tuesday oh
that's what i thought okay last girl was
not fully committed by the way she just
oh she killed herself oh
moments later with the umbrella yeah
yeah i mean i took a took a couple of
saws yeah but when she opened it up yeah
yeah yeah i mean it really tricks you
gotta put your tiny wrists into it yeah
you really in your binded and uh here
and we're gonna uh here's another clip
and this brings us to the final point
where what they want to do when you see
this with the left when you see this
with john oliver
okay and i'm making a generalization but
let me ask you this
have you ever seen john oliver stephen
colbert trevor noah jimmy kimmel have
you ever seen them do a segment and and
i really do i want you to comment
because correct me if i'm wrong where
they've said
to any minority group as we do regularly
on the show hey you know what
some people have had some some unfair
breaks and we get it but the good news
is you can do it and the good news is
you're actually not oppressed and it
doesn't have to continue that way you
live in the freest country in the world
with the most upward mobility and you
know what i believe in you i don't think
it's a racial issue have you ever seen
them say that or have you always seen
them make generalizations based on race
while then bitching about people who
make generalizations based on race so
this is how he ends up closing his
segment his lesson for you and we're
going to have some actual solutions here
i think some pragmatic solutions do
matter and they're pretty easy simple
stuff
like john oliver erect the statue in my
honor simple things
asian americans continue to be oppressed
mr oliver says but there is no nice
racism there is no silver lining to it
and there is no working your way out of
it you are still perpetually treated as
a foreigner still asked where you're
really from and asian americans always
seem to be just one geopolitical crisis
away from becoming the target of
violence yet again
so the model minority myth is both a
tool of white supremacy and a trap
okay so a couple of things here
violence against asians okay
where's that stem from
over 85 percent of all
physical assault crimes in the bay area
right
liberal bastion and freedom it's
paradise take place at the hands of
black americans against asian americans
could it be the soft on crime laws
when he talks about uh all these other
all these other issues as far as you
can't get out of it you're one crisis so
wait well hold on a second here a lot of
asian americans statistically they are
out of it
and to me saying that
is why you created this segment you've
accused people who say that that they're
out of it of being racist and using the
model minority you see the problem here
there's no way there's no way out of it
you're going to have white people saying
look asians are doing well and cheering
you on okay
it seems to me like that's a way out of
it but if we point out that there's a
way out of it you accuse us of being
racist this is the thing they need
racism to be a modern boogeyman and then
they don't care about the collateral
damage they don't care about the
collateral damage of anti-asian hate
crimes that take place they want to
blame it on donald trump they don't care
about the collateral damage while
they're discussing here later he does a
segment on affirmative action well let's
discuss that where's the collateral
damage of affirmative action the supreme
court's going to be hearing a case on uh
harvard and university of north carolina
north carolina i think uh there's a
harvard applicant actually this is a
famous uh story if you haven't read up
on it harrison chen who scored nearly a
perfect s.a.t graduated top of his class
and he wrote they just lumped me into
the asian category and the data quite
clearly shows that admission officers
were not willing to look at us
as individuals do you have any idea how
many bamboo chips that kid had shoved up
his thumbs by his mom to get a perfect
sat score well look not getting into
harvard's probably a silver you know
they're silver lining to this thing here
there's a set so yeah yeah it's probably
a good thing you dodged a bullet hang
out with the likes of barack obama and
ted cruz oh come on daddy with a
chopstick
you are not harvard material like colin
jost
now hold on a second though where have
we heard about uh you know this this uh
applicant harrison chen were we heard
about lumping all asians
together before i feel like
one of the main dangers of treating
asian americans as a single entity is
that it obscures the reality of what is
happening for the different subgroups
inside it what are the dangers of
treating asian americans as a singular
minority in also telling you that
there's no way out asian americans for
crying out loud this is what happened do
you really believe that it's the right
who's the party of divide and conquer i
mean it's kind of like this usually in a
relationship in a romantic relationship
okay
you end up someone is either explosive
someone is either you know gets mad or
someone is incredibly manipulative
someone who gets mad is not really all
that clever they can't control their
emotions so they're not capable
of being manipulative yeah this is the
issue here when they say republicans
conservatives look they were the party
of slavery they were the party of the
kkk all of which is incorrect well then
they wouldn't really be able to
tactfully find new ways of racism like
not admitting asians into harvard and
brown that's you guys you're
manipulative well they're racist towards
the right groups though right they're
they're racist towards white people
they're racist towards asians they're
saying that black people in this
specific case he's targeting black
people and saying
that they need to be able to have a leg
up they need affirmative action to be
able to get into these universities even
though they don't match on the scores
potentially right not all right and
that's okay and that's acceptable but if
you just say look i want to get rid of
male female and race on any of these
applications they would say no no no
that's racist because you'll just end up
with a bunch of asian people and maybe
some white guys in there as well
that's his entire sounds about right
well with john oliver he's like he's
like a reese's there's no wrong way to
be right
okay but why not
if you really want to base this on
individuality then yes you would look at
them and go you're perfect for harvard
exactly the same as you would look at a
dynamite athlete who may not have the
best grades that would be perfect for
your basketball team or your football
team right well if i were the harvard
admissions i would say you know i'd have
a little fun with it i'd say you're
perfect for harvard oh yeah i'm kidding
don't have orientation oh oreo i'm just
joking have fun
if yeah maybe you could be like you
could uh i don't know you you're right
for penn state you look like you could
be molested in a shower right exactly i
don't think they have that at all i
don't think you're right for brown you
should apply to yellow i'm kidding
welcome aboard you know that's what i
would do
gotta have a sense of humor about this
because i'm colorblind
you know how go go say you know who
wrote really well about this obviously
everything that he writes is fantastic
hitler thomas soul who was whoopi
goldberg
about the asians was hitler the pan
pacific it wasn't child it wasn't about
racism i've had enough of your
your poops and giggles right
who we had on the show this guy is one
of the most brilliant thinkers out there
happens to be a black man by the way and
he is against having affirmative action
get people into schools that they can't
necessarily
meet the standards for yeah that will
actually be
it would actually be a negative thing
for them because if they go to a school
that they can perform it's like look at
lottery winners what typically happens
you're like somebody who didn't earn the
money they get the money hey you have
money now they tend to blow it all and
be in poverty and lose it all he's
saying the same thing like wanted to
make one truck if they can't meet the
academic standards they'll get there and
they will possibly fail and it will be
crushing to them whereas instead they
can go to a fantastic university that
has great credentials and do exceedingly
well well thomas sol or as uh if you
guys watched our wikipedia expose as uh
wikipedia refers to him not a reliable
source ah because we can't take do you
have any more of that krugman give me
give me give me i need krugman i need
krugman let's say this you're from a
horrible neighborhood
but you do attend school regularly yeah
for example all of that's right
uh but you are from a horrible
neighborhood you do pretty good in
school you do have decent grades your
sats aren't necessarily
insanely high but they are very good do
you think there should be some sort of
uh
no not not none whatsoever no no no
because you know why when you don't you
end up with ben carson the first doctor
to separate conjoined twins
right
and then he's accused of being racist
the guy was from detroit single mom yes
tried to stab her was only only stopped
by her belt buckle i didn't know that
she wear a kevlar buckle so he tried to
stab his mom rot and then just off the
charts brilliant and made it and
the thing is too um you have a lot of
white people from crappy areas but but i
mean was he
an example of somebody who
always was
uh at the top of his heart
no no that's the thing he turned his
life around he turned his life right he
was in a very very bad area and he
turned his life around and people want
to say that it's racist this idea to say
look anyone needs to
eventually take responsibility for their
own actions and try and do well and that
there is there is no i here's what i
would say i understand the point that
you're making i think it's not a point
it's a question question no i understand
the question and i think it's base it's
based uh i think it comes from a place
of empathy i think we're looking at the
wrong place to start so let me offer a
couple of quick solutions here okay
before we talk about should there be
some leniency all right that's like
looking at a car your car won't work and
rather than looking at the engine or the
transmission you're looking at the rear
hubcap bolt you know uh
what do we do we just talked about
earlier do you guys remember do you guys
remember what it is the single greatest
indicator that we have for economic
success for relationship success for
mental health
two parent households okay so what do we
need to do let me give you a couple of
easy solutions people say what can we do
about this this issue is so complicated
of race and do we have more leniency
from people who are in crappy
neighborhoods do we spend more money
well hold on a second
you're gonna throw more money at it
because for people spending is higher in
detroit than on average for people
spending is very high in dc the worse
schools in the country than on average
more money doesn't help it okay are we
going to say that like you talked about
we're going to say that let being more
lenient on admissions is going to help
well no because then we see the highest
dropout rates for black americans who
get through
affirmative action you know basically
they're used to meet certain racial
quotas and then they end up falling
behind and then ends up having a worse
economic outlook they end up with a
worse economic outlook so those things
don't work here are some simple
solutions when we talk about where we
can start okay
first off we've been talking about
immigration here in this country we've
been talking about getting people here
we're talking about asian americans
really first let's have a national
language okay let's have a national
language let's have some criteria for
immigrants who come to this country
because we want immigrants to come to
this country to actually have the best
chance possible to be successful and
their children to flourish okay what
else do we do let's have some policy
that encourages two-parent households
here's the thing if you believe that
taxation if you believe that economic
policy particularly fiscal policies it
relates to taxation is a good
manipulator of behavior this is what the
left believes this is why they want to
attack cigarettes this is why they want
to tax big gulps for crying out this is
why they want to tax gasoline more this
is why they want a carbon tax if you
believe that
then you would have to acknowledge that
the inverse is true let's let's continue
to provide some economic incentives to
reward people who are to uh who create
and foster a two-parent household in a
nuclear family as opposed to trying to
destroy it like black lives matter oh
again people you align yourselves with
uh and let's also have some you know
what not have some laws let's eliminate
all laws on the books that exist right
now
to incentivize in any way shape or form
single-parent households so that means
the welfare laws that means the ebt laws
that means the laws that created a baby
mama that means laws that say oh you
know what you get two welfare checks if
you're not officially made but if you're
a couple you only get one let's get rid
of so it's that simple national language
let's incentivize two parent households
and not only that culturally let's try
and start celebrating a little bit and
let's get rid of all laws that exist on
the books that could even possibly
incentivize the opposite single-parent
households you start with that that's
going to do a whole lot more than
doubling the per-pupil spending or
doubling the amount of black americans
who are accepted into harvard which
means that you will get half the amount
of qualified asians who are accepted in
harvard regardless of how much money you
throw at it there's a starting point
there's a solution if you agree look you
can comment below you can smash that
like button we're going to continue
talking about this in a way that we
can't talk about on youtube because
they'll just accuse you of being racist
and we're going to play newest gender
pronouns so youtube you can piss off
you